let's take a stroll back to the
beginning of the 20th century with the
russians with the russians so
their interpretation goes like this
everybody was right the state is crucial
we were right we were the
revolutionaries we seized the state here
in russia
now we have the state and socialism is
when the working class
captures this state either by reform a
revolution and then uses its power over
the state to make the transition from
capitalism to the better thing we're
going toward
and again make a long story short in the
interest of time
what happens which is not unusual in
human history
is that the means
becomes the end
in other words lenin who's crystal clear
before he doesn't live very low he dies
in 23 so he's only in power from 17 to
22 but that time he has his brain
trouble not 1923 by the way not at age
23 yeah yeah before listening 1923 yeah
he's only there for four or five years
uh he's very clear he even says and i've
done work on i've published so i mean i
know this stuff
he says in a famous speech let's not
fool ourselves
we have captured the state but we don't
have socialism we have to create that we
have to move
towards that
um
with stalin you know lenin dies and
there's a fight between stalin and
trotsky
loses the fight he's exiled he goes to
mexico stalin is now alone in power and
does all the things he's famous or
infamous for
um
and by the end of the 20s stalin
makes a decision i mean not him it's not
that he makes it alone but
things have evolved in russia so that
they do the following they declare
that they are
socialism in other words
socialism becomes
when you capture the state
not when the state capture has enabled
you to do x y z other things no no the
state itself
once you have it is socialism so when a
socialist captures the state that's
socialism exactly
and hat
that's exactly right
and they feel like that's definitionally
confusing well it shouldn't be because
here we get an example yeah
if you go to many parts of the united
states today and you ask people
what's socialism
they'll tell you they look you right in
the face and they'll say the post office
and you you know when i first heard this
as a young man you know what
the post office
it took me a while to understand the
post office amtrak the tennessee
all the examples in the united states
where the government
runs something
this is
socialism
see capitalism is if the government
doesn't run it if a private individual
who's not a government official runs it
well then it's capitalism if the
government takes it then it's socialist
so what is wrong with that
reasoning so the idea i think
there's nothing wrong with it's a way of
looking at the world it's just got
nothing to do with marx
you